how we wrote in saying hey when it comes
to fake news stories is it the fault of
journalists for spreading it or is it
the fault of the public for believing it
I don't think there's a simple answer to
this question I think there are a couple
things going on number one media
literacy is embarrassingly bad in this
country and I go and I'll speak at high
schools and colleges about media
literacy and understanding at least the
putative difference between opinion
journalism and news journalism and what
it claims to be and how our analyses of
bias or or truth would be different
depending on whether we are supposedly
interpreting an opinion or a news report
from something like Reuters or The
Associated Press so low media literacy
and the social media echo chamber
confirmation bias desires could be areas
in which we say the public has some
responsibility for determining what is
real and what is fake news particularly
when we have a First Amendment and you
can't just make it illegal to say you
can't publish quote fake news because
who determines whether something is real
or fake
that's number one number two though
there is no doubt that many I don't even
really call them journalists I call them
I guess they're entrepreneurs that's
really the term have made a ton of money
perfecting and growing deliberately fake
news media outlets I've read a lot about
them there's some really good
investigations that have been done a lot
of really good articles that have been
published about this you can't say that
the publisher of fake news has no
responsibility at all for fake news
being out there I mean they're the ones
putting it out there after all yeah so I
think there's three entities here
there's the journalists themselves
there's the platform's where their news
is going on and then there's the users
that are taking it in that first step
they're the journalists I mean most of
the time they're deliberately putting
out this fake news so of course they're
not going to take the responsibility on
themselves and you know counteract what
they're already doing that's what
they're out to do and then there's a
platforms like Facebook and Twitter and
we have seen them start to crack down on
fake news yet although it's been risky
for them from a PR perspective
definitely yeah it's tough to do too
because I mean do you have a strike
policy if someone inaccurately tweets
out something retweets out something are
you just going to shut them down
permanently
and what I well how do you say something
is fake news I mean there's one approach
which is if there are websites that are
generally known for parroting unsourced
stories we're no longer going to make a
call about individual articles we're
just going to say hosts from X website
are not allowed that's one way but then
if you're going to take it on an article
by article basis if an article has 90%
accurate facts and ends with an
incorrect conclusion is that fake news I
don't know I'm not sure where the line
is I mean sometimes it's just very clear
I saw on Facebook this idea that if
Donald Trump was ever going to run for
president he would run as a Republican
right because those voters are so easy
to convince this was a quote attributed
to him and then another after the
election there was a thing being spread
that Harambee got some 40,000 votes yes
not true so when they're you know making
these quotes and statistics that you can
just kind of disprove easily that's
obviously thank you I think the the risk
is anytime someone becomes the arbiter
of what is real or what is fake you are
going to have to make some calls that
come down to political opinion and
that's where I think it gets very very
very risky no matter whose fault it is
if news consumers were significantly
more media literate there would be far
less of a market for fake news so I
think that maybe we can't control unless
you want to change the First Amendment
purveyors of fake news what you can
control is your own media literacy and
your ability to discern real and fake
news and I think as an individual that's
the most important thing you can do
you're going to be hard to shut down
fake news as an individual much easier
to get educated about how you should be
an interpreter of the news that you get
that's where I'd focus my efforts yeah a
lot of this comes down to just personal
responsibility checking your sources I
mean decades ago you'd be able to watch
network television or get your local
paper and be able to trust what they
have to say but now with all these
different media outlets that you have to
choose between some of them conspiracy
websites some of them far right far less
you really have to check your source and
dig into what they're saying and people
are busy right are you going to source
watch check every single thing you read
I mean that would be great but people
are busy if they read stuff up there so
Media feeds on the bonus show today
three great stories I'm out of time so I
won't even tell you what they are but
they'll be really good I can assure you
david pakman.com slash donate to check
out the campaign david pakman.com slash
membership to sign up for membership
coupon code
I voted 17